cannot turn down people's choice so well
are we continuing of what I discussed
yesterday but but I want to explain
maybe a little bit more intuitions and
so the plan is to our discuss the design
of the the the procedure the linear
estimator and why it looks like a design
a filter the linear estimator and then
why it looks like a filter design then I
want to discuss the impossibility result
and what what is the bad distribution
without the worst instance ensemble
things that looks like what's the bad
and I will discuss some extensions
limitations and other related open
problems right so to this so let's get
started
the set up is I have n samples and I
want to know how large is the support
support size not the set is number of
non-zeros
none zero month okay this work
what okay and now we want to ask what's
the minimum sample you need for which we
need to constrain the distribution and
to have some lower bound on meaning mass
I'll discuss this later
the but what I know is P belong to a set
of distributions which is all
distributions which each mass is either
0 or bigger than something I just okay
so right and that is I define and star
of N and K and epsilon which is the
minimum sample size such that you can
find estimator which is belong to the
truth plus minus K of Epsilon with high
probability I can put constant
probability with probability at least
90% right ye p belong to this set so
this is the statistical fundamental
limit if you wish and the goal is to
characterize this and find a good
procedure entertainer right so I showed
you that the result is sub Li
right yeah okay this is better so it's
sub linear in K indeed and the
dependence on the how accurate your
estimate is is fully logarithmic instead
of polynomial which is what the previous
results showed okay so I want to discuss
some something about so there are a lot
of procedures along these lines so there
are linear estimators and also nonlinear
estimators veneer in what in the
sufficient statistics the fingerprint
which is histogram of the histogram
number of items appeared has appeared
exactly J times right and this is the
number of appearances of the ice guy so
this is the histogram so Vinny as the
mirrors meaning why I'm going to design
some F that applies to every histogram
or equivalently this is a linear
combination of some appropriately chosen
coefficients price to the fingerprint
so the seeing estimator is just some
everything up and this is estimate is
what you see and also there are other
good for men with oscillating
coefficient and also a frothy stud about
design different coefficient right now
I'll focus on this but I think it's fair
to to discuss other nonlinear estimators
of not all this form just briefly and
there is for example a pattern maximum
likelihood that Olinsky at all designed
which also you can use it to estimate
the sport also there are linear
programming this method that I will not
discuss and they are also let's say
coverage based does it mean so coverage
based meaning first I want to estimate
the following quantity which is a total
probability of everything have observed
which is a summation of P I of
everything that that appeared in my data
so this is some probability and 1 minus
C is the probability that next is new
conditioning oh my okay so this is
usually called coverage and I know my
the total number of observed samples is
the under estimate so I should inflate
it a little bit right so the way to do
it is if I have a good estimate
for coverage I just blow it up well that
it will give me some reasonable estimate
right it will be less under biased but
and one of the ways to do this is to do
good terrain and then in this way it's
some nonlinear function of the histor
print and there also so this is another
one oh yeah so I I said put some
estimate here for example go touring for
example good-turing this is one minus H
one of them right it's some heuristics
but the idea is that you want to inflate
it and also there is a maximum
likelihood estimate of course now you
need to say what's the family of
distributions you're looking at and for
example you can do uniform distribution
that will be one family of distribution
parameterize by exactly the size of the
support and you can find the equation
for the maximum likelihood and has been
analyzed works pretty well in the
uniform case so pattern maximenko them
and and this scootering also proved
Ollie actually in the special case where
the distribution is flat but you see
that the worst case the bad instance of
distributions are actually very very non
flat so this is a little bit about the
design of coefficient like this right so
so this is the upper bound what I will
do is I say I would do the following if
you think about it and I want to know
the this quantity so this is just in
terms of bias
I want the expectation of these to
resemble this function right so what I
do is the following
you've got a difference
well the first thing I said is I have a
first design principle which is if
something is NP R I say it zero okay so
if the corresponding mass is zero and
then it won't appear and therefore I'm
also zero therefore I can put the
indicator outside and I also know by
some friend if it is non zero then it'll
at least one or okay I'll do this right
and also I have another design principle
which if something appeared for many
many times I just add one so another
design is if it is bigger than one if it
is bigger than some threshold I'd say
okay that's in the alphabet so in other
words there's also further simple advice
to the indicator where appeared less
than L because it's bigger than I'm
exactly good
now here another implication with
hyperopia here the following is going to
happen if something out of n samples
appeared at most L times the
corresponding mass will not be bigger
than two air over n with high
probability right so if L is not
sufficiently small so L is roughly a log
of n know of K so with high probability
I'm very confident then whenever
something appeared no more than L the
mass is at most well Ren
okay now I can't expectation on both
side and this who becomes expectation of
this quantity so here is the little bit
of variations I can either to put on
something or not I can even without
doing it so let's do it so the personal
sampling me instead of n samples
I personally am posed and it's just a
see relaxation but it doesn't appear it
doesn't hurt me much and you will see
it's not important at this stage so what
this is is a half i minus 1 by factorial
e to the minus end p of j and of p LJ i
from 1 to well and then there is these
indicators of the probabilities belong
to this little interval 1 over n L over
ok now you see that this is nothing more
than each of the minus end of pj times
some polynomial in P of J so what I
really want is this guy to look like the
following behavior
so I have one constraint is that the
polynomial has to pass through minus 1
at 0 because it's this is minus 1 so the
picture is the following this is this is
minus 1 so whatever the polynomial I
pick has to pass through here and this
is my little interval whenever okay I
mean if you do that if you view this as
a variable and this is 1 over N and this
is 2a well and I have to pass through
here and I want to have minimum
oscillation over this period so this is
looks exactly what you were doing if you
design a fine and order filters and the
best design is Jerry Jeff so this is the
maximum loss I suffer which is roughly e
to the square root of n over and this is
precisely degree L chebyshev polynomial
shifted and scaled and the coefficient
are readily available if you compute
until done so this is very much the idea
here and just give you a concrete
example if you have let's say you have a
million items and you have let's say
point two million samples what does the
estimator looks like the estimators
looks like the following seven h0 is
something appeared once I say there are
seven more times that - 25 - and go on
and so forth and this is 75 H 3 minus
something so this is the oscillation
part and starting from 12 13 14 so on
and so forth the signal-to-noise ratio
is very good so I can just say they are
in the alphabet right so this is the
this is the flat part and the degree
here is 11 so this is what I implemented
on some data but roughly the this is
what it looks like
yes minutes right in some intervals yes
absolutely so you yeah so actually so
instead of a low-pass filters you design
something that is like that right we
just want to count the number of
elements with probability greater
actually that won't work so that's what
Ramone suggested but I'll come back to
that later
it's you have to you have to be careful
with how do you define the problem log a
log of you can put a log in here yeah so
if you have media example this is
roughly 10 knows no I know
yeah yeah yeah right so I'll dress your
question now actually so I so I think
Ramon suggests yesterday is instead of
estimating the total non zeros and the
inch imposing the constraint that is
bigger than something
let me just estimate the probability of
the heavy hitters bigger than that right
and I want to so let's call it RFP this
and I want to impose no constraint on
the distributions and I only care about
the big guys but I mean it's very easy
to see that this won't work because
consider two instance of one over K is
completely uniform and let me put a zero
here and Q is 1 over K minus Epsilon
okay absolute epsilon22 I don't know to
dota 2 to the minus n right so you won't
distinguish these two sample
distribution if you collect and samples
but what is R for this it is okay for
this is zero
yes so it won't so just it's a it's
essentially in this case you can to only
do one side inference if you don't you
only can say okay I give you you can
only estimate
well maybe the support is at least how
big right and you want to push that
upper bound as aggressively as possible
because you can always be very
conservative
and due to the usual plugin but you want
to have much time I think five okay so
let me explain to you the main idea of
the lower bound and what does it look
like the bad distributions right so you
want to construct actually you simply
want to solve the following problem
in fact there's two hypothesis testing
one is SP is bigger than is less than
something at 0 P is bigger than s1 so
you want to of course maximize this to
the point that with n samples you want
to be able to distinguish right so it's
a composite hypothesis testing so you
need to design some good the Kovacs
combinations on these two hypotheses so
that they're they're convex combination
becomes almost indistinguishable but I
want to just say the main idea of design
these distributions which are random so
think about the following idea so if I
have written random variable U which is
drawn through some law of meal and you
has the property that has one unit mean
and positive I can generate
distributions of the following form I
have K copies of them and I say this is
my distribution of course it won't
normalize right it is not only so if
this is the probability simplex this is
not going to be on the support the
previous in plug but it's only withing a
little bit of fluctuations because the
sum of the probabilities is one with law
of large numbers plus minus standard
deviation of U divided by root K right
so you will not be fixed you will grow
with the sample size within everything
but as long as you make sure this is
like law K or even if you know K to the
one-third you can ensure you are in a
small tube along the probability simplex
so you can effectively treat this as
probability distributions
let's not discuss that but I want to
give you some examples of this form
so examples U is constant in other words
is is drawn through Delta 1 what does it
look like P is exactly uniform
distributions right yes okay so another
example U is takes two values 0 or 2
with probability 1/2 well ha so if you
draw the corresponding distribution what
does it look like it look like very much
like uniform distribution on half of the
alphabet and the support is uniformly
peaked right so it is roughly the the
symmetrized version of this type of
things I can also give you let's say
uniformly chosen from the interval 0 to
2 then if you draw and K copies of this
you will get a distribution where all
the probabilities are going to be
different right anyway so the the role
of you plays the shape of the histogram
of this distribution and the goal is to
design something that makes them design
two shapes that generated us with
indistinguishable histogram but I I
don't have time to go into that but I
just want to give you the idea of what
does it look like
so the at the end of the day the
distributions will look like the
following and this is another P prime so
they are these are the two Nemesis that
and so these are think about these are
you drawn from you and this is drawn
from you Prime and you and you prime
actually only takes log values this is
not important for the proof but I want
to just give you some intuitions and so
you have you know you won over K and
this is what the probability that u
equal to u 1 times K so a fraction of
the alphabet take these values fraction
of this take this and there's and the
biggest mass and the smallest mass
actually very differs a lot so in a
special case of the sub linear regime
cable ok I have around locate samples
and the ratio of the biggest mass the
smallest mass is around log square so
there are very young you know form and
and in this case you can you can show
that the construction that yield this is
roughly I will just put some constant
point 5 K and this is 0.6 so they are
constant fraction of the alphabet is
populated and somehow you you pick these
things very in such a way that you match
the moments and then and they generate
the data that is indistinguishable but
these are the rough ideas okay yeah all
right I'll just stop here and you can we
can discuss about other open problems
there